the u.s trucking industry is a 700
billion
behemoth which is higher than the gdps
of 150 countries
though the trucking industry doesn't see
the explosions that are common within
the tech sector
they have consistently been growing a
solid three to five percent annually
year after year after year in fact
with current projections there's
actually expected to be a trucker
shortage by 2026.
unfortunately however the 7.7
million people working in the trucking
industry today should brace for
disruption
as the tesla semi enters the market
[Music]
starting off switching over to electric
autonomous trucks
is a no-brainer for retailers and
logistics companies
as the savings are quite substantial
walmart has
already secured 130 semi-trucks from
tesla
worth tens of millions of dollars and
they have committed to switch to 100
electric by 2040 now that is a bit of a
longer time frame
but i think walmart is just giving
themselves extra time to switch over
thus the vast majority of transitions
will be complete
by 2030-2035 and
if you don't believe me then just take a
look at the cost savings starting with
fuel expenses
currently the average loaded semi-truck
in the us
only get six miles per gallon the best
trucks
are able to push up to eight and a half
and even ten and a half miles per gallon
so we'll give the edge to traditional
trucks and call it eight miles per
gallon
the average semi truck is driven 45 000
miles per year
meaning that they consume approximately
5 625 gallons of diesel
per year according to the u.s energy
information administration
the retail price of diesel per gallon is
in the lower mid twos
but this is after a recent crash in
march and april
if we take a look at the average price
per gallon over the past three years
this actually comes out to nearly three
dollars per gallon
but again we'll give the trucking
industry a bit of an edge
and call it 2.75 cents per gallon
this means that with 5 625 gallons of
diesel per year
this would run you 15 468 in fuel
expenses
per year per truck with tesla on the
other hand
they advertise less than two kilowatt
hours per mile
so what is color too as of august 2020
the average price per kilowatt hour was
just 13.31 cents
now of course using tesla's supercharger
network
would actually cost these companies 25
cents per kilowatt hour
however i doubt that this will be the
path that they choose
as we don't see semi trucks pulling up
to regular gas stations
today over the past few decades
companies have been significantly
reducing the distance
between their warehouses and their final
destinations
in fact in 2005 the average length of
long-haul routes was
800 miles but by 2012
this was only 500 miles and this rate of
decline is said to simply be
accelerating
considering this i think it's pretty
safe to assume that companies will
ensure that the vast majority of their
routes are conservatively less than 500
miles
which is the max that tesla semi can
handle
this way they can charge the trucks
themselves at their warehouses
and then at their retail locations
meaning that they won't have to deal
with any third-party charging networks
which will likely overcharge them for
electricity
thus companies will end up paying the
u.s average
of 13.31 cents per kilowatt hour if not
less
for the same 45 000 miles per year
we get fuel expenses of just under 12
this means that each tesla semi truck
will save the company
three to four thousand dollars per year
just in fuel expenses
over the average 15 to 16 year lifespan
of a semi truck
that comes out to over fifty thousand
dollars in savings
moving on we of course have autonomy
tesla has been making significant
strides towards
fully autonomous vehicles and if you
have checked out their latest fsd beta
you'll know that it's officially just a
matter of time
until tesla cracks the code currently
full self driving from tesla only cost
ten thousand dollars
which is expensive for the average
person but an extraordinary deal for
commercial customers
however it's very unlikely that tesla
will sell full self-driving to logistics
companies
and retailers for just ten thousand
dollars elon musk has previously tweeted
that with regulatory approval full self
driving is worth over one hundred
thousand dollars
but given that customers like walmart
and sam's club will be buying these
tesla semi trucks in bulk
will say that they'll be able to score
100 000
per autonomous truck license this is an
enormous upfront cost
even for commercial customers as it
increases the cost of the truck by
over 50 percent right from the start but
they of course will consider the long
term in which this price
is still a steal the thing is the
average semi-truck driver
gets paid between 28 and 40 cents per
mile
calling it in the middle we have 34
cents per mile
the average truck driving 45 000 miles
per year for 16 years
would rack up 720 000 miles
given that tesla has been working on
developing a million mile battery
and may very well have already been
unofficially successful
at doing so handling 720 000 miles
shouldn't be a problem anyways dividing
the 100 000
autonomous software cost by 720 000
miles
we get a per mile price of just under 14
cents
which is a 59 reduction in comparison to
the average truck driver
over the lifespan of a traditional semi
truck approximately 244 thousand
eight hundred dollars will go towards
trucker pay which is upwards of 150
000 more expensive than autonomy
software from tesla
aside from this there is one more
important factor to consider
which is efficiency long-haul truckers
generally work very hard but
unfortunately
humans simply cannot compete with the
efficiency of a machine
that needs no rest whatsoever truckers
need to sleep
eat and take breaks to avoid driving
fatigue and potentially dangerous
driving
in fact truckers are limited to driving
11 hours per day
even if autonomous trucks were only as
efficient as human
truckers they can simply drive longer
every single day
if the average trucker is able to drive
up to 11 hours per day
the average autonomous truck can likely
drive 22 hours per day
really the only down time with tesla
semi
is the charging time and companies can
pair up a lot of the charging time with
unloading and loading times building up
a gas station
for semi trucks behind each target is
extremely expensive and doesn't make
sense
but putting in a couple of superchargers
in the unloading zone
isn't that expensive and would save
charging time
during the actual trip with that being
said
tesla semi trucks will be able to work
for at least twice the time
of the average trucker before we get
into the total cost savings per truck
there are several smaller savings as
well when switching over to electric
autonomous trucks
first of all companies won't have to pay
for the insurance of their workers
nor their medicare and social security
taxes
on top of this companies will also
likely profit from cheaper insurance
bills for their trucks
as a proven autonomy system is likely
much safer than human truckers
they'll probably also benefit from less
maintenance
as there are less parts that can go bad
with electric vehicles
not to mention they don't have to deal
with oil changes
and emissions inspections and what about
tax write-offs and incentives for
switching to electric vehicles
really there are a plethora of smaller
cost advantages for switching to tesla
semis
which will likely add up to tens of
thousands of dollars themselves
over the truck's lifespan with that
being said
let's figure out the total cost savings
for truck the traditional semi truck
cost between 130
and 200 thousand dollars we'll call it
160 thousand dollars
on average saying that the average truck
travels
750 000 miles before being retired fuel
costs would come out to 257 thousand
eight hundred twelve dollars and trucker
pay would come out to 255
000 which comes out to a total of six
hundred seventy two thousand
eight hundred and twelve dollars
throughout the truck's lifetime
tesla on the other hand charges 150 000
for the 300 mile version and 180 000
for the 500 mile version considering
that this
is long haul trucking we'll assume that
most buyers go with the 500 mile variant
over 750 000 miles we would see
electricity costs of 199
650 or right about 200 grand adding on
another 100 grand for the autonomy
software
we have a total cost of 480 000
which is 192 000 cheaper than
traditional trucks
adding in all of the smaller benefits we
previously outlined
tesla semi trucks will save well over
two hundred thousand dollars each
to make things even worse for
traditional trucking tesla semis will be
twice as efficient
meaning that companies will only have to
buy half as many
so for every two traditional semi trucks
company's own
which cost them a total of 1.345 million
they only have to buy one tesla semi
which would cost them
480 000 this means that each tesla semi
is equivalent to about 2.8
traditional semis also let's be clear
here
we give traditional trucks the advantage
throughout all of this
we assumed that the average truck was
actually more fuel efficient than they
really are
we assumed that diesel prices are lower
than they usually are
and we assume that truckers drive the
full 11 hours per day
every single day of the week so our
total 200 000
costing estimation per truck is actually
extremely conservative
in fact tesla themselves estimate that
fuel savings alone
will be more than two hundred thousand
dollars so when they come out with their
autonomy cost-saving estimates
we'll probably see them throw out a
total of three hundred to four hundred
thousand dollars in savings per truck
which would indicate that each tesla
semi is equivalent to four to five
traditional semis
anyways whatever the final number is
it's no question that tesla semi
is multiples more cost effective than
the average semi today
meaning that the industry will instantly
shift to tesla semis
as soon as it's possible simply to make
more money
thus devastating the traditional
long-haul trucking industry
when do you guys predict this transition
will occur comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys hope that
our long-haul truckers are able to find
employment
soon after this transition and of course
consider checking out our community
discord to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm ari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one
you